hey everybody and welcome to an
absolutely incredible wild ride with
stevo
we have the return of the legend tony
hawk
who last year i got together with to do
a
double wall ride photos of which we both
signed for charity and i'm happy to
announce
that the signed photos of our double
wall ride
are back on sale once again 100
of the proceeds are going to charity to
support tony hawk's foundation the
skatepark project and if you hurry up
you got a good chance of getting one
so go to stevo.com if you want one other
than that what can i say
calling this guy my friend is a major
honor
and this podcast was a really good time
so let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen tony hawk yeah
dude the triumphant return
thank you guys you guys have come a long
way
we really have dude um you're our very
first ever podcast
guest and i remember after recording
that i was like dude
if ever a podcast goes that well i'll be
so stoked
yeah i just thought it was such a home
run
and then like we sent it to our podcast
guy and he was like
no way really he says maybe you could
let him talk a little bit
wow that's kind of frightening because
i started a podcast with jason ellis
right uh hawk vs wolf we have not
released one yet first one's out on may
24th but
right i saw you posted about that with
uh lizzie on it but that's
and so that's how i feel about it you
know i was like dude if we get this
right this is where we start right but i
haven't had that feedback yet so
i worry yeah well but then again i do
that man i i it's something that i've
had to work on i thought that podcasting
was gonna be like
a cool way to promote tours you know
like even like a revenue stream
and i come to learn that it would help
me like
grow as a communicator
[Laughter]
like much needed growth that's like the
safest version
of what you could say i guess
what made you decide to do a podcast um
i honestly it was it was stuff like this
that i like i know that
uh i was doing siriusxm show for
15 years you loved it and and i got it
it's fun i had this conversation with
jason yesterday jason ellis because
i feel like he and i both got way better
at being
interviewers as siriusxm got
lower i got less interested in us
you know what i mean like we were we
were on this trajectory and we were just
getting buried
and i mean you know they i understand
they've got a ton of other shows but i
felt like oh man
my last few guests i had seth rogen i
had pharrell
you know and and they were good
interviews as far as i was concerned and
so
jason's like yeah man same i was like
let's just do something let's bring it
back because he and i started on sirius
together right uh and so i feel like
between us
we have a lot of stories dude jason's
got himself right i think so jason his
stories veer more towards
your antics but we balance each other
out
for sure and and i mean that's something
i would always notice when i was on tour
like oh dude what are you gonna go on
you know ellis radio again like i
noticed that his his fan base
is really rabid they're they're really
into him yeah and he brings
obviously he brings his fan base that he
had on siriusxm and to his podcasts um
and then
hopefully i bring mine as well and uh
we've done a few already and i feel like
they weren't
they you know they were funny i mean
definitely
i was entertained i remember you telling
me about the
accident that lizzie had yeah so i
didn't realize it was quite as grave as
it sounded in that
that post yeah so that came about
um i told her early on
not you know as when she was in recovery
i just said hey if you ever want to tell
your story i'd be happy to
be the one to talk to you about it in
any form however we do it and then we
started the podcast and i told her that
and then out of the blue she called me
and she said i think i'm ready to
tell my story because that happened back
in october she had a
heavy i don't know when and for anybody
who doesn't know who lizzie is she's a
professional skateboarder she rides for
your company birdhouse
and she's really like among the biggest
names in
in women's skateboarding yeah absolutely
she's uh
she's one of the most popular female
skaters uh
really successful competitor i mean as
far as i'm concerned one of the best
and she had this traumatic crash
in october at elliot sloane's mega ramp
right um so basically she
she went kind of leaned too far
forward as she was getting to the jump
because i think she was anticipating it
sooner and it sent her into the back of
the landing ramp
so about 25 30 feet across
you know going i don't know 30 miles an
hour or so
and then she slammed into the back of
the ramp
and then she had to fall another
18 20 feet [ __ ] yeah god so
just full you know ping pong
just boom and then onto the ground i
mean it was heavy it was it was really
traumatic the whole birdhouse team was
there because we were shooting for that
right
war rig thing and um you know that we we
covered the entire thing
uh from her perspective on our show and
uh
it's it's it's like top
three heaviest things i've ever seen on
a skateboard like right up there
yeah i mean jake brown jake and then
lizzy
and i don't know which ones is gnarlier
it sounds like lizzie's was more
consequential i mean it's like like
jake's was magnificent like he came from
like 40 feet in the air and like his
shoes came off and
yeah but i don't know that he had quite
the like the hardware put in yeah i
don't really i don't
it's it's all subjective i don't want to
compare too much yeah it was
it was really crazy and and it just it
also is a testament to her
dedication and perseverance that she
could come back from that because
right you know it's the kind of crash
that it definitely could
end the career if not worse right and
she's skating and she just
she just learned no complies up a step
up
like i know that seems minor but when
you see
what happened to her you won't believe
that she's back learning tricks
yeah dude and then and i just realized
too that the another like hugely
prominent female skateboarder this
this very young girl sky brown
you were she had a she had a bad touch
i know that one i wasn't around for that
one in fact
even though it was at your warehouse so
it was yeah and
unfortunately it was a it was a trick
that i think i would have discouraged
her from
uh-huh if i had seen her trying it you
know what i mean like
there's a part of me that i saw i was
like oh man i would have told her that
dude that's so it's so interesting i
never thought that that this would
be sort of the you know where our
conversation
went but did you see the documentary
called the crash reel yes
and i i feel like pierce yeah kevin
pierce he was a pro
snowboarder he lives locally here now
too right yeah
great he's a great guy he's awesome yeah
but
you know not to get into the into like
the details of that documentary but i
just bring it up because it's such an
indictment of action sports where
you've got all these athletes and and
they just have so much pressure on them
to keep pushing further and further
like like go higher and higher and like
do more and more dangerous stuff
i i agree with you in that the world we
live in and and
there's a lot of pressure on everyone to
perform and whatnot but but i also know
that
in the heart of everyone especially the
the people who are
who are successful you can't stop them
right and i know that because i am that
guy that you couldn't stop
right you know and i did stuff that were
beyond
what i what risks i should have been
taking at the time
but you know it's like matt hoffman yeah
there's a party that wants to like
uh don't right don't do it matt and he's
like you can't
didn't you get his blood didn't you make
it like until
you were filming like a commercial for
the gap in like the 2000s or something
without breaking a bone
what can i say i know a lot about tony
hawk
and i love the guy and i also
love this time of year man spring is
just
time to get outdoors and enjoy your
friends there's no better way to do that
than around a big old
campfire that's why i'm so excited about
my new toy
my fire pit from solo stove
this thing lives in the cargo box on my
rv
at all times i have pulled it out no
less than twice a week ever since i got
it
i'm like addicted to the thing i set it
up outside our warehouse
we saw up our pallets for firewood
which is great because we have so many
pallets we're going through and they'd
be piling up if we weren't burning them
and we'd get in our little chairs we'd
get around the fire we always have a
great time man
this thing's so solidly constructed and
it's got its own little ventilation
thing
which makes it like virtually smokeless
you don't stink like the fire in your
clothes or anything
and then just when it's done you know
like you
dump out the ashes and stick it back in
the box i love this thing
and i want you to give it a shot and not
only if you use the promo code
stevo at checkout when you go to
solostove.com to buy one
if you use the promo code steve or you
get a free stand with your fire pit
and that way you can set it on the stand
and not
damage a wooden deck that you might be
on or or
whatever on the ground it's a good call
and it's a good deal
so i want you to go to solostove.com use
the promo code stevo
at checkout that gets you the free stand
and hurry up while it's this time of
year you can get around that fire with
your friends and just have a great time
you're going to thank me for it so hurry
up and go do that right now
and let's hear about tony breaking his
first bone
yeah 98 really 98 broke
broke my elbow on a gap commercial after
how many years of not breaking anything
i mean he's been professional since the
seven years yeah
i mean yeah but i had plenty of injuries
yeah
you know i know that that the whole idea
is like how many bones have you broken
right like well i had
two knee surgeries and like at least 10
concussions up to that point and
you know fractured this and that and
bent whatever but um but yeah
but it was i knew it right when i hit
i i did uh i did a um
weddle backside 180 over this fun box i
mean i could tell you the story it's
pretty funny because
sure it was out of time it's 98 so i
wasn't really making money and i got i
got a gap commercial i was like dude
you know this is awesome and you know
you get whatever
rate you get for the day and and the
idea that you're gonna get royalties
going forward
like residuals from the commercial that
was the whole thing it's just like right
this could be my income for the next six
months
so luckily we shot vert they had a vert
ramp there we shot the vert stuff before
we got into this other thing
and so they got their vert footage and
then we were going over this launch box
and that that was the big thing back
then right it was like x
games type of stuff you know launch
launch kicker launch box
and then flat on the top and then a
wedge ramp down like that was the thing
bmx roller blading skateboarding
and so i went over it and then i was
just like
i gotta give him something more so i
decided i'm gonna do a
a baxter 180 you know well grab and
like in japan and they're like all right
action i did it and landed it
like barely cleared it and they're like
ah we didn't move the camera fast enough
can you do that one again
i just knew when they said that i was
like i don't know if i could do that
again was jeff germain the director
and so then i i drop in do it commit to
it i knew i didn't have enough speed
and you know did the deck check thing
where like
two wheels land on the flat two and my
body was committed to going down
so i basically ejected to the ground
and you know that was like i don't know
eight feet or something
but landed on my elbow and thought that
i i don't know i thought i'd bruise my
rib or my lung or something
and then as soon as i came up i could
just see this thing
like moving the wrong way on my elbow
and immediately i i felt nauseous
and i knew right then i was like i broke
it man
and i was just like dude of all the
times
when i would really actually need the
money it's crazy
they pay you extra because you broke
something for a gap commercial or no
well that's
that was the the weird part about it is
that i went to the hospital
um and the doctor told me he's like no
you didn't break it
you're fine i'm just like this thing's
like moving around it's pretty obvious
yeah and then he comes back after x-ray
is like oh
i didn't i stand corrected you broke it
and uh so because i got hurt
during the shoot i was uh they put me on
um on workman's comp
so they said you know you'll get money
every week that you're not working
and i said well i i do have sponsors i
do get paid
and they said yeah but if you're not
working in commercials i was like well i
rarely work in commercials anyway
like i'm trying to dispute the fact that
they're trying to pay me workman's comps
yeah it just felt weird
and they're like well you know how if
you were to do commercials how much
would you make and i said well as much
as this
one i guess and i said okay well then
you get
500 a month and i was like
what it's crazy to me to hear you say
that
in 1998 you weren't making money
like yeah i mean i was i was i was
scraping by
right right around it was more like the
years prior to that i was it was
it was i was hurting like i had to i had
to downsize and
sell a house and i had to yeah and it
makes sense to me i mean i know that
like
throughout the 80s it was like this
crazy skateboarding boom
and then the 90s kind of got quiet
especially for vert skates yeah yeah i'd
say
92 to 96 were the
like the most struggle in terms of right
trying to make it as a skater
uh trying to support a family uh
you know and and just but but at some
point it was just like all right that's
what we gotta do
you know i'm eating top ramen i mean
taco bell i was skating a birdhouse
skateboard in 94.
a jeremy klein that's that's how i
afford to talk about it
yeah dude dude dude hold on
dude the actual birdhouse board okay
because i always want to like uh
have some indication on the top of the
board what the tail and where the nose
is
oh yeah so dude that board that jeremy
klein i i uh
took the panel from a taco bell a
mexican pizza box
yeah and i taped it across the board
like uh and then laid the grip tape so
it was just it looked like it was a
professional taco bell skateboard wow
that's how full circle is this circle
yeah and that was the one that i did
uh like the cleanest 360 double flip
like
you know skating on flat ground that's
crazy yeah
but the other thing about that is um so
i
actually had this conversation with
spike not that long ago
in case you're wondering the spike that
tony is referring to
is the academy award-winning movie
director
i wonder what they were talking about
but i don't wonder what i'm going to
tell you right now
which is that i am very comfortable
sitting in my seat because my butthole
is clean as a whistle
why because i've got my bidday from
hellotushi
fixed to just about every toilet i
regularly use
and i love this product man i won't shut
up about it if you heard me on
two bears one cave big huge podcast that
just came out a few days ago
i couldn't shut up about it on there i
love this product
why it's great for the environment
you're not throwing away all kinds of
toilet paper because when you get done
taking a big sloppy dump
you just twist the little knob which is
fixed to your toilet once it's set up
and you get this refreshing blast
of water right onto your butthole it's
like washing your [ __ ] with a
pressure cleaner it's the greatest
invention ever
and when you get done blasting it then
you just take a
little tiny bit of toilet paper just to
dry it off and for that
satisfaction of licking that toilet
paper and seeing that there is no poop
on it because your butthole is so
clean man i can't recommend this product
enough
and i really really think if you haven't
tried it yet that you are missing out in
a big way but don't worry because i got
a great deal for you
if you go to hello hellotushy.com
stevo by using that special slash stevo
at the end of hellotushy.com
you're going to get 10 off your order
plus
free shipping again that's ten percent
off your order plus free shipping
at hellotushy.com stevo
and not only will you thank me but
believe me your butthole
and your underwear will thank me so get
on over there and do that
and let's hear about spike jones uh
i remember if i got something like i got
you know a commercial i was like dude i
gotta come i'm gonna get you know
400 bucks for the day or whatever i was
like we're going out we're going to
olive garden
that was the celebration that was the
big like that was going out
yeah that was the really you know it was
a nice restaurant and i remember i had
the same conversation with spikes like
do you remember
like going out right awesome dinner was
olive garden i was like yes
yeah macaroni grill yeah
now you're an investor in your own
restaurants and so that's the seller
yeah that's wild
but to answer your question i mean to
finish that story
uh when i was getting money no no i i
take
i was getting like 400 or 500 a week not
a month
on workman's comp so i'm making more
money because i'm hurt
right it was just a weird thing i felt
really strange about it
and but it was definitely helping like
you know i could pay my mortgage
and i was able to survive and i was
still trying to heal and when i
and then um they said well you just let
us know when you're working again
like in a commercial yeah and then i got
a call
from 18t uh
on the east coast when everything you
know when it was all splintered
he said we want you to do a commercial
for um at t
because we have this new credit card or
something and i was like
cool can you could you just jump
could you jump through a wall of glitter
onto a crash pad and i was like i can do
that with my elbow yes absolutely
and so then i had to call the workman's
comp company and say i'm working again
[Laughter]
fine that's great what's crazy was that
you the more
400 a week paid your mortgage now that
wouldn't even come anywhere near a
mortgage
oh yeah yeah i think my mortgage was
about 1200 a month
it's yeah but that's the other thing you
know like
we were all just doing it because
whatever you could do to not get a real
job right
[Music]
so having experienced like the boom and
then
you know like the the peaks and valleys
is that a wonder because i look at how
hard you hustle
and i'm just always like impressed and
and almost confused i feel like why does
tony
why is tony hawk hustle so hard
and uh i i suppose maybe that that helps
to explain it or that just
kind of built into um i i definitely got
into that
cycle and it's hard to break yeah
but also there's part of me that is like
strike while it's hot yeah you know what
this is
crazy the opportunities i'm getting
right now are it just unreal
like they're dreamy dude like i just saw
your mercedes
i'm like dude i've seen i've seen you
like
you know team up with so many like cool
sponsorships
and i just get jealous like who gets
i even sent an email to someone on your
team like
who gets tony all of these cool deals
and like can i talk to that person i'll
tell you
they said it was uh your manager lady
named sheila is that right sandy
sandy yeah but i'll tell you what how
that came about so i i think it's
because
especially right now like i've done i've
done four
pretty big shoots in the last month um
which
was you know a couple of even years ago
three or four years ago didn't happen
once a year um but uh
i think it's because i was able to stay
productive through kovid
you know and kind of be out there
whatever how in whatever form
skating and and you know making things
work doing live streams doing your shows
stuff like that
and when things started to come back
around as we start emerging from
all this chaos uh people are just like
oh that guy he's he's doing stuff like
right
yeah i mean it's it's crazy and and dude
have we gone this far and not mentioned
what
you and i did during covid when we did
the double wall ride
and uh it would that was still
such a runaway success yeah how many
people did not believe
we ended up selling it like it was so we
would tony does this thing he's like you
know
uh gets his amazing picture doing a full
uh a full pipe
loop yeah and and he sells i saw it like
i bought one i was so stoked on it
it's in my house and uh it was to raise
money for covid
and it's like 50 for covert 50 for the
skatepark project i think um
yeah and i think on that one we were
doing uh
we were trying to help the fires in
australia right okay
um it was all for charity and and and i
loved it and then
that motivated me to uh get behind
because dude when the
when the pandemic hit it was like you
know miles and miles of
lines of cars and people waiting to get
food and i'm just like people can't
eat dude so i wanted to get behind a
food bank
and i just straight stole tony's idea
you know like
i just sold signed prints to raise money
for a food bank and then
and then i reached out to you i was like
yo man
i stole your idea it went great and you
were like let's do a doubles photo
we'll do a double wall ride and i mean
well that came from
you trying to recreate your wall ride as
a kid right right right right and
you came you brought a you brought
[Music]
it was like how how hard could you
possibly slam on this
not that hard
what gave you the idea to say let's do a
double wall ride which was just
completely reckless
well i was like i was like that's your
redemption let's figure out how
we both can do it right and i mean and
i'm such a liability in that situation
but we got this
epic photo and and i remember thinking
okay like i've sold and signed prince
tony's sold signed prince probably
everybody who wants our signature has
one
you know now we're like going back to
the well and like here we here
you know here we go probably no one's
gonna want it i remember thinking
i felt the same way like i mean i was
like really we should do twenty five
hundred i had two thousand you know
and uh and so that we put them on sale
and i'm like i remember nerds i was
nervously checking the app to see how
many sales there were
it had been up for like 20 minutes
and it was and and the app said we had
raised like
20 000 i thought i was like reading it
wrong i was like oh man only 20 bucks
like wait
what i couldn't even fathom how much
money was coming in
and it was 100 of it for charities i'm
just like oh my god
here we're and i'm thinking like why
when it's 100 of it for charity is that
the one thing
[Laughter]
the one thing that i can sell yeah but
dear but
i was so happy man well i learned a lot
from that too and and
i learned that especially with those
things
you got to have the story behind it yeah
and and the way you present it is
important
right and the video you guys made of us
figuring that out and why we did it
right and this
was really the the central to why it was
successful i think
i think even more so that the video
really chronicled like
our history going back like yeah for
literally decades now which is crazy
and uh that kind of got people a little
bit invested in it
i so i remember this vivid moment when
you were like let's just go let's just
keep signing
right and i said cool yeah let's do it
you know this is amazing
because we didn't even have a number
like we didn't have a number
i think we had i don't know how many we
had signed but we got to a point where
we were selling more than we had signed
and and we checked in it was like all
right let's just [ __ ] keep selling
and we'll just keep signing so we're on
this like
just frantic [ __ ] crazy like
just it took over our lives for like the
next like a week or two
and we weren't even down here so we were
driving from l.a
right right back yeah so he would sign
whatever right a couple thousand and
then your guy would meet us there or
vice versa
you guys would bring him down right i
would get him i'd frantically start
doing it then someone drives into
riverside to get him
to get him shipped out it was but it was
it was non-stop for
a few weeks but i do remember this one
moment because you're like dude they
just keep selling it keeps selling and
right and then at some point it got to
the point where it's like we'll get to a
million this is gonna be
crazy and you came and you're like we
sold
we were at up to like 11 or 12 000.
yeah right the number of right
and and so you came to my house with
this giant box
and uh and i was thinking like yeah
we're getting there
and i said so how many is that like ten
thousand you go
this is six
like once you sign this giant box right
here
right we're halfway there right and
that's when we both looked at each other
and we're like we
can't keep doing it and i had only put
that video on
youtube i had not put it on my facebook
or my instagram so
like we we really could have sold way
more
and we just got burned out on it but
then now here we are
we got back together the triumphant
return of tony hawk to the wild ride
podcast
and we're putting them back on sale i'll
have said that in the intro to this
but uh but yeah like we're gonna [ __ ]
raise
more money and again a hundred percent
for charity
yeah i still get people reaching out to
me like hey when can i get those
available again
so everybody asking yeah it's been much
more pleasant to do that at my pace
right at my own pace right uh so you
know i just signed that box there's like
a thousand or fifteen hundred but it was
just more like when i have
an extra 15-20 minutes i'm gonna burn
through these and i'm gonna go do my
other stuff it doesn't take all the time
away from my kids like
are you guys gonna have a limit of what
you're gonna sell this time or are you
gonna
i think it makes sense go for the glory
it's so crazy because i'm i'm right back
in the place of thinking like i don't
know man we already like i don't know
how many we can sell
i mean come on dude i don't know yeah
but hey i appreciate
you spent so much time and effort doing
that and
when we finally did stop the sales the
first time
we were at 480 thousand well right i
mean technically
the app said we were over half a million
but what i didn't factor in
was that there was a two point nine
percent credit card
fee the shopify swipe every time you
slide these things so
so this this glorious over half a
million number
just got chopped down to 480 000 and i
remember saying
wait let me let me shine here this guy
he wanted to present a check for half a
million dollars so
badly that he's like i'll just i'll just
chip in the extra 20 grand
okay so you're gonna devote all your
time and effort to signing stuff
for our charity and then it's gonna cost
you twenty thousand dollars i'm like
that's not acceptable four hundred and
eighty thousand dollars
is an amazing number to get to let's
leave it at that
yeah the ocd would cost you 20 grand
dude
i would have done it i i would have done
it happily and
and uh yeah i'm psycho you know
but uh dude i love that video though i
i love it's still an amazing video yeah
it was it was really it was a fun
project and and it was it was hard man
that was like
yeah it was not easy to figure out the
timing and that the the landing ramp was
that wasn't really steep so it felt like
you're coming down
too flat and flat again um that was a
gigantic
frontside wall ride that you did and
that was a liability
no but it was gigantic out of
desperation right
to try to keep away from you
[Laughter]
the higher i go the safer i am yeah yeah
it was you were you did fine you made it
more than i did all right but i also
like did it really small i mean whatever
like it did
it was amazing yeah it was amazing and
uh we're back at it we're we're raising
more money for the tar
the the skatepark project skatepark
project thank you
yeah i'm i am so appreciative and
everyone on the staff and that was our
biggest fundraiser
yeah to date today and dude
like i i cool i uh
gets i would i want to say i get such a
kick out of it but it's more just like i
i can't even believe it's like i'm bros
with tony hawk
and you know i mean it's probably
it's like lame to say that but like when
when i tell my
bros when i my buddies from high school
i'm still in touch with all of them we
were like a little skate gang
and when i sent them the photo of me you
and i doing that wall ride
like my bros from high school like i
cannot put into
like words the impact that that had you
know
it was like oh my god and one of them i
got to introduce you to my buddy
abdullah
oh yeah yes that's right yeah it's just
it's pretty cool man so like
when you say you're appreciative i'm
thinking like man like i got to do that
you know it was it was i guess
i'm still blown away um that we got to
do it that it resonated
and that we raised that much money and
it was that was unreal and and then we
celebrated by going to surf ranch and
you got barreled
yeah turns out tony hawk and stevo's
like chocolate and peanut butter man
yeah so dude um i'm
i was on like this great
program with my food i was not eating
flour or sugar like as a rule and i got
like
okay how much did you lose i mean i
didn't even i just
i just was healthy and just wanted to
look good yeah i didn't i didn't beat
myself up over portion control i just
just avoided flour and sugar and you're
good and then i fell off you know
you know when i when i had my relapse
was at your dumb restaurant
is that a is that a plug for urban sea
or is that like is that are we
done make sure you go to this dumb
restaurant
amazing restaurant encinitas yeah by the
way it is completely amazing the dessert
is so good you will relapse if you're on
any kind of diet dude
i had made it i had made it i think like
10 or 11 months
no flour no sugar i remember we were
there with you guys and i was and i held
my
my boundary and then i went back with my
girl
reading there this nice little table and
on the patio
the food was unbelievable and after the
meal the the waiter comes over and says
hey
you know so we got this extra dessert
like uh some somebody ordered an extra
one or something with like you know i
got enough like it's not
i'm just gonna leave it here it was a
lava cake and i and i took
i took one bite of that lava cake and
then
my you know i'm an addict dude so now
i'm just like in trouble with my weight
dude like
you wouldn't notice it unless they take
my shirt off and then it's
i'm a disaster dude and i don't i was
curious
have you ever had like where you're like
just got out of control and
put on a ton of weight um not a ton
uh as i got older and slowed down i
could see that
you know i don't look as fit as i used
to but you're always skating
i'm sure i'm trying to escape regularly
yeah and
and that becomes more challenging too
just with
kids and obligations and things like
that but but i but i do it's more like
an effort now
you used to just be like oh man go skate
look at it and now it's like okay
like today i know i have this window
from three to five
yeah gonna make it count you know i'm
gonna go skate like that's what's gonna
happen but um
to answer your question i used to not
care
when i was like anything i was just
eating all the impact people would be
like dude how do you how do you eat four
meals a day i'm just like
i have to and i was just you know always
on the go and
and my metabolism was fast and then as i
slowed down i realized like oh there is
an effect to all this
i would say that when i noticed it
um was through covid and i was
drinking more than usual okay you know
and to a point where i was just like
come on
right because we were just so idle and
i'm sure it went you know whatever i'm
making making excuses but
it seemed like a lot of people were
going through that where they were just
at home
and it was just like oh have a glass of
whiskey right
whiskey or wine mostly whiskey um
you know it's more like we'd be up
watching something and all of a sudden
the next thing i know i'm
like oh i'm falling asleep very quickly
i can't picture you being like that like
uh i don't drink it too much like
like turning into a darth or something
like that you know i don't think that
could ever happen no i but i do enjoy
fine whiskey so i i'm gonna leave that
at that and yeah i still you and the
rock oh another rock drinks tequila huh
i don't know yeah um so but that was
when i noticed and that's when i was
like all right you know
don't don't do this to excess right and
i felt like i was doing it to excess and
so
that's just keeping that in check it
takes discipline
for sure but but yeah it's not like
it's not like it used to be i was just
going
yeah and desserts let's go like
you know ground slams for breakfast yes
i yeah i got
i got it but but i'm this today's day
five i'm back off of
sugar and flour how do you avoid that i
mean it's
it's just kind of within reason right
like you're not going to completely
avoid sugar but if like sugar is like
one of the top like three or five
ingredients then
you know there's probably no carbs and
no bread
like yeah i've definitely cut back on
bread yeah
can't have bread man um okay so i wanted
to ask you this too
have you ever had on any level like a
public
feud like um
that's a good question uh
not a campaign it's not something you
picture you can't picture anybody like
man [ __ ] tony hawk yeah
i i definitely i've definitely stood up
for myself and you know on social media
when getting
i remember when uh the people gave you
teeth and stuff people gave you heat
over doing a got milk ad
and i remember i remember you standing
up uh saying like i drink milk man i
don't understand the heat
right but that wasn't like anything like
like oh i did but i did one i did one
last year through
it did it again and i i put
milk on my corn flakes this morning so
oh dude that's right you did the mctwist
with the milk yeah yeah yeah that was on
tmz it was amazing what's so bad about
drinking milk
i mean some people animal people animals
yeah and
dairy industry and you know there's a
lot there's there is controversy and
right i i respect people's opinions but
this is what i do like i'm not
i'm not changing my values to get paid
right but i got milk right i drink milk
like i i enjoy it i like milk yeah i
like it and i put it on my cereal and
sometimes in you know coffee or i eat
ice cream
and and i have my whole life
so it's it you know you i think the the
issue is that people say like oh you're
so i was like dude
this is what i've been doing right i
love that
i love that but i bring this up because
like the whole has
tony hawk ever had a feud because
i had like a situation with somebody
and and i was inclined to like
be on my podcast and and tell this story
and complain about it and like
you know and i actually did i won't even
say which podcast it was
but i was doing my little evening
meditation
and and it just i was i was thinking man
like am i going to leave this
this rant where i go up and tell this
negative story
in my part and and what what
made what made my decision i was like
tony hawk would never do that
like i guess the closest thing to a feud
or any sort of thing like that would be
you know this this whole nonsense of
like i i stole the 900 from tus papa
i'm sure he was not in the x games and
all that is fabricated
um and and you know i stand by it but at
the same time i don't want to
i don't want to you know there's there's
there's a point where just like you
don't
people just going to believe what they
believe right they want sometimes they
want to believe
right those things because they don't
they don't want to believe that it could
be really
that spontaneous or special and and it i
just have to let that go
and that's fine and so you know there's
also the whole thing like you
don't protest too much like if you're
fighting it so hard it just looks like
you're
right you're guilty of this thing you're
being accused of and
i i know what happened i i know
it's true and real and i i didn't
step on anyone's toes or steal something
from someone or or
do these manipulations and so i just
have to accept that
but it is it is very
it's hard it's hard to restrain yourself
when you're just like dude
right was it hard to read not real
was it hard to restrain yourself when
steve said that he was a better street
skater
it wasn't because because if he's doing
double 360 on the flat he was a better
street skater
he was like yeah you probably are but
dude i wasn't even man
i did that was i so you know going back
to that whole story when he was on his
red email list i chose to be off the rad
email list which i probably shouldn't
have
done like i i guess i replied all like
i'm out i
don't i'm tired
he asked this email list is too big who
wants out
so i can add more people in i was like i
don't have time to read them
it was a test right he wanted to see you
[Laughter]
somebody's out and they just get blasted
oh no they no i got blasted
but not but i was not included in the
blast email
oh so other people were sending it to me
i'm pretty sure i sent it to you i kept
you on to blasters
you were never even that rad you still
have those emails i think i haven't seen
it before i would love to read it
you know what i i believe that there
archived on the internet by someone just
completely random
i remember i i had i had some
communication with
uh baba bowie gary de la box yeah and
right then because they wanted me to be
on the uh the wrap-up show
yeah and uh i said i said
dude are you on the stevo thing he's
like yeah man you can just
feel the drugs when you read it right
jesus
right i know man when when's the last
time that you were
on the stern show uh i i've only i've
never been on the show itself i was on
the wrap-up show yeah
uh a couple times and i'm a big fan so
you know when i'm on the wrap-up show i
can hold my own in terms of knowing
what's going on with the show
and the dynamics who's your favorite uh
wack pack oh man that's hard
wow you know what to do yeah
i i do i love eric but
eric like i can't remember he said
something about me and
he's like tony hit his head one too many
times
at least he knows who i am yeah eric the
actor
yeah i like eric the actor you know the
actor was he was the best he was
yeah like it's like it's like howard
said he would just he would just
fight to the death like on whatever it
was
and hold his ground and you know and
that's amazing so
yeah for sure but um uh i do love
wendy because did you see here when
wendy was the judge
on the they had some
kerfuffle and and wendy had to be the
judge on whether uh
right or whether someone was allowed in
the wack pack yeah high pitch was like
yeah and
and she was awesome and i was like yes
yeah well all right on man what uh
what other stuff can we let people know
about there's like get on the
the hawk versus wolf podcast yeah that's
coming uh
first show will be may 24th and then um
where can they work in the year 15th uh
wherever podcasts are yeah we'll we'll
be out there yeah
we'll make it happen um sam jones is
actually working on a documentary about
my life
nice he's kind of wrapping up the
interviews now so that's been
interesting cathartic weird
okay i was never i don't know it wasn't
like i was ever
trying to do that you know what i mean
like
who who wants my life story i was just
he he brought me the idea
and i trust his work and his uh
his sensibilities and i was like yeah
you're the guy i'm shocked that there
hasn't already been
like a definitive tony hawk documentary
there was one
in the early 2000s that was like more of
an espn piece
right um but this one is is
way deeper and the footage that he's
uncovered is
unreal dude you're so good at social
media
with all that like always digging up the
the all this great so a lot of a lot of
the stuff that i've put out in the last
couple months
has been because of what he's been
uncovering and he'll send me a link like
dude
contest and the cool thing about sam i
don't know if people know sam jones is a
prolific photographer
he did the documentary about wilco um
welcome the band okay uh there's people
listening like yeah dude i heard
it's really good it's very good and um
he said uh check this out i found myself
in the crowd at this upland contest
like he's a hardcore skater wow
nice upland so he was a wittier local
like he skated
i mean you know for skaters that's
that's a very small population
that's cool yeah dude ah
so so when's that coming out uh i don't
know
there's tony's in the works you said
what's in the works that's the same
okay good man what do you got going on
here i did
eleven i gotta pitch a tv show oh [ __ ]
yeah
okay should we wrap it up real quick
we're wrapped up let's wrap it up
i'm kind of dying to be like hey guys
what's up
[Laughter]
you want to get them on zoom right now
well i mean i need to get on zoom
uh i say are you overlapping right now
wow look at this we're in the podcast
and he's getting on a zoom
pitch how's that timing this is next
level dude yeah
i know dude you're all biz yeah you talk
about the hustle
i i i can hustle a little bit yeah
the chiropractor from here you're
hustling
what's this for steve i guess we're
shoot this away he just looked down at
his phone and i was like i thought he
was going to show you a photo but i
guess we're down here
business meeting man all right well
we're thank you tony hawk
thank you for that serpent don't let the
door heat on the way out
all right bye everyone thanks for having
me
oh man you're the best what can i say
being friends with tony hawk
dude it's crazy i gotta just try not to
kiss his butt too much
but he's a hero and if you want his
autograph
with my autograph on the same totally
epic photo of us doing a double wall
ride
like i said at the top of this episode
they are back on sale
and uh i i'm curious to see how long
they last
full disclosure we signed uh 1 300 of
them
and we're going to sign more but i think
they're gonna fly
and like they went on ebay for like 290
bucks or something i think
tony said we're the new supreme in any
case if you want to get one
and for sticking around to the end of
the episode you know i love you thank
you so much